[Music]
anthony flores
how's it going thanks for coming on the
show i'm
really happy to be here i'm so pumped
for this me too
we have neurofeedback we have meditation
consciousness enlightened states
yes it's a crucial
topic maximize our well-being
moment to moment our family's well-being
our friends well-being
our communities well-being the world's
well-being
just through a deeper awareness
to our own states of being of experience
and how to re-baseline them to higher
states yeah absolutely
yeah such a crucial topic i'm so
grateful to have you on and grateful to
shaker pie for
introducing us shaker's the best love
you shaker thank you very much
and let's
jump in we have some assets that we'll
be showing i'm really excited and we'll
be breaking those down
anthony let's talk about your journey
and how you
got interested in this space
sure um i was surrounded by spirituality
when i went eastern spirituality when i
was young
i had an aunt who was buddhist i had
other people in an
indian guru um path and
i was also really nerdy so i ended up
going to stanford university and um
i didn't know what i wanted to do once i
got there because i didn't realize i
didn't want to be a doctor or a lawyer
or engineer
and so i decided to just choose an
audacious goal and like walk onto the
tennis team but i wasn't good enough
so i started studying and there was a
book called the inner game
of tennis that was all about zen applied
to tennis
so i got really obsessed with zen
meditation
and i went to like a zen center every
week and i was just doing
50 books like i did everything i could
to kind of evolve
in zen and um i also
so that was one aspect of it and then
another one was that um
i happened to just go into a
chiropractic um
office in palo alto which i think it was
fate that
it was a method um called network spinal
analysis by this guy donnie epstein
who um it looks really weird but
basically through light touches either
to the spine or even
in the field of the body outside of the
spine the spine will start to oscillate
and wave on its own without the person
trying to do anything and
that starts to send like current and you
know energy and information
up the spinal cord so where um
you start to become aware of you know
how old there's all this energy at the
root of your spine and then how that
energy flows up and it can
go to your head um and i ended up doing
because that was like my freshman year
ended up doing like
500 of these sessions so
it really opened up something
energetically in my spine
um and i would experience sometimes
awakened states or oneness states
in those sessions or after those
sessions and um
it planted a seed for what i experienced
are
you know and what i kind of evolved in
with neurofeedback later on
that was a big those were like two very
big early things that
shaped my my journey for sure
so you had early exposure
to spirituality specifically buddhism
yep okay and then you also had the
what was the other one we were talking
about shot
oh
it's a very devotional path they have a
living guru and they um
two and a half hours of meditation a day
and um
strict vows around lifestyle purity and
things like that
so yeah it's a very serious kind of
spiritual path
yeah and we were just looking it up and
talking about it a bit
because i had interestingly have
dived into so many of the planetary
spiritualities but
even some of them i'm still not super
familiar with and sant mats one of them
s-a-n-t space m-a-t for those that are
interested in looking it up
and it's it's so interesting the reason
why the word perennial just continues
stick
over and over again is because even
while we were looking at sanma
even online that it shows that the same
idea of
accessing that inner wisdom of
understanding tatava masi like you
are that like we are that just the most
fundamental no matter what indigenous
civilization or no matter what
mystic tradition it is it's the really
the ice cream no matter what flavor it
is
is like right here yes yeah yeah
yeah it's it's based on um something
called
suritshabad yoga which is basically a
yoga of light and sound
so it but light and sound are universal
to every
every spiritual tradition so yeah yeah
and then you had this other really
interesting
second aspect to that which was
and you you mentioned joe dispenza
before we started as well
and he has a it's becoming supernatural
and he talks a lot about being able to
just
do what in you know in like theravada
buddhism you have these experiences
where
you feel kundalini awakenings there's
many attributic traditions where you
feel these kundalini awakenings but
specifically from theravada you take a
10-day period to
just strictly practice
your respiration and your focus and
your ability to have
extremely high sensitivity and so
it makes sense to me that when you talk
about chiropractic when you talk about
the spine and when you talk about the
ability to sort of
hone one's attention more frequently on
trying to in a sense do something it
would look it kind of looks something
like you know like
you know it is kind of that that that
process
um and you know even as you do that
standing up straight with the shoulders
back
tight yeah you feel a current yeah
yeah yeah exactly yeah
and there's um related to buddhism so
another
i mean there's so much serendipity so
fast forward
um into when i became a writer later on
and i was
interning with this really legendary
writer in the space
and one of the other interns had studied
quite extensively in buddhism with
this author that's written a bunch of
books his name is bill beaudry
and he has a lot of books that
address just the physical part of the
spiritual awakening
process and basically he studied with
the last enlightened zen master
master nan who um their tradition they
really mapped out all the physical
transformations that take place as
somebody becomes
enlightened and um he would say that a
lot of people what people experiencing
and kind of when they think that they're
having a kundalini awakening it's
basically like pre
kundalini it's like the spine getting
ready that an actual true kundalini
awakening is actually quite rare because
you're
a full kundalini awakening means that
you're enlightened like at that stage
that's like level one of enlightenment
is
a full-blown kundalini awakening so um
and they have actually specific
practices so one of the things i learned
from him was something called a white
skeleton meditation
that they practice um that apparently
was developed by
buddha himself to accelerate the opening
of qi channels so
in this white skeleton meditation you
would actually visualize
all the flesh coming off your body and
then picture your skeleton
and then actually feel your entire
skeleton from head to toe
and then feel white light moving through
every
kind of you know atom of your skeleton
is as vividly as possible
and that clears channels and basically
that
is um is including the spine it
basically helps open up the spine as
well so
that's like an accelerated one of the
reasons why it became popular in
esoteric
zen and buddhism is because it's a more
rapid way like a lot of people's
limitations
in going to samadhi and into like
enlightenment are
just that their chi channels are not
open enough they haven't done that
that kind of preliminary work and so
those kinds of practices can make it
um easier for you the physical aspect to
get into
samadhi and beyond
yeah our our analogy for
this we talk about a lot is that you
can't just walk onto the
basketball court and start draining
three-pointers or you can't just pick up
the violin and start
playing bach and so i think it's
super good that you point out that
there's this sort of baby step process
of becoming
more and more sensitive because
immediately upon birth i mean there's
i'll give you the two polarities
you have the one polarity which is
you're born into
the right away right into the metropolis
right into the economic machinery
right into stimulus as after stimulus
and the other sort of polarity is that
you have
like the kogi in colombia indigenous of
the
sierra nevada de santa martin mountain
range down there
they have um
their their mamas from age up from birth
until nine years old will live in the
cave
they'll live in the darkness and so now
you see the other polarity which is
which is no no
sensory stimuli only only
uh darkness only only what feels like
spirit or what feels like
uh soul or essence or it
and so the idea is that after the age of
nine you're
when you go out in the world you're
gonna be a shaman you know you're gonna
be
a master of reality
and so it's it's important to
recognize what you're saying that there
are these experiences where
you undergo a note
and it's funny because even science is
starting to slowly and slowly
as we unpack quantum mechanics we're
starting to in
biochemistry biophysics once we start
you know really unpacking that more and
more you know you can actually
tap your awareness into the tiniest
little
changes that are occurring on a
moment-to-moment basis like in your foot
in your knee in your calf in your waist
yeah
and then you gain a lot of incredible
insight
into like
even pre-trigger which is usually you
get triggered into being like
ow and then you do it but you can begin
becoming more sensitive so that you can
actually
pre pathology you can make corrections
this is a lot of really important stuff
right off the bat
and that makes sense with your
trajectory and your journey that these
were kind of the
the keys and then you kind of gave us a
bit on
on on writing was that did that end up
being
uh so how did how did like it seems like
there's some sort of a
uh coalescing of of fields that kind of
happened
into maybe your like late 20s and
figuring that out so yeah
yeah i mean i knew that i i didn't want
a conventional path but i didn't know
what i wanted to do and somebody handed
me a marketing book while i was working
on
health optimization and working with
just different supplement companies kind
of
um at a lower level and then i realized
like wow this is something that i could
do
basically to be and you know have
autonomous
with my own life and lifestyle and how
much money i made where i lived and all
that stuff i just didn't
i had freedom is a very big value for me
value for me so i was
like very reticent to give it up to be
like stuck in an office um so i just
and then i started to see a pathway
where i could pursue that and
be successful and i um yeah i just got
really obsessed
with it and ended up really fortunate
being really fortunate with mentors
and one of which is the one that i met
that i went to north carolina with this
guy named clayton makepeace
and um that's where i met
the other other kind of student who
exposed me to even more kind of
meditation and cultivation techniques um
and the writing
is what i loved about it is it's amazing
um it's an amazing skill i mean it's
it's it's on a universal skill having
it's
basically communication yeah so um
it's opened a lot of doors like for me
um you know i even the first
neurofeedback intensive
i i did a partial trade with the company
where i helped them with their writing
and their marketing and
they let me come because those intenses
are very expensive so
it's just served me in so many ways um
and it's a passion
but it's like the spirituality and the
neurofeedback and other things are just
increasingly like more of
my more like mission it's like i guess
the distinction is
meditation and awakening and
spirituality is more of the mission and
writing is a skill that supports sports
yeah and so then when was it
recently that you had the
really strong transition to just this
vast majority of your attention and
focus on neurofeedback and meditation
and beginning to do the quantified self
version
which we'll show the graphics of sure um
yeah i was
i'd just gotten out of a really long um
relationship
and i had was in an unhealthy space just
in terms of
ending but also very addicted to
caffeine and stimulants and
pushing myself and um i knew i needed to
make a shift and i'd heard
um about this training called
biocybernaut
that is basically like seven days of
alpha training with
forgiveness work um that you do every
day
and usually do about four to five hours
of neurofeedback a day and then you work
with a therapist
when you're not in the neurofeed
neurofeedback basically to determine
what you need to let go of and the the
premise
of it is that everybody knows
forgiveness is powerful the bible talks
about it it's very much in pop culture
now but
um the forgiveness i think that we
generally do
um is more surface we don't actually
release the result the underlying pain
and the underlying resentment that is
associated with
that um that resentment and so um
as you go deeper into alpha and you do
this process
um that they walk you through which some
of the components are beginning with
actually like really feeling the pain
as intensely as you can and being in an
alpha state helps you
do that because alpha is all about
feeling you know alpha's very much
connected to the heart so the more that
you feel the more
um sensitive you're you are into that
to that pain and so you do that and then
you um
there's some other things that you use
for empathy like you walk in their shoes
and you and you recognize like the gift
that came from whatever happened to you
that you need to forgive
and um and then you go and there's a
couple more steps and you let go
um and you really actually see in real
time
like because your your scores are
present for you actually while you're in
this
this dark room and your eyes are closed
but then
every two minutes the scores will flash
on the screen as you do
these series of forgivenesses and so you
can see when you let go of something big
all of a sudden the the scream lights up
and you're like wow you really
see and then after they debrief and you
can actually see
your alpha improve every session where
you just keep forgiving and forgiving
and forgiving and
and um yeah you really ultimately
realize i think we
we're kind of taught whether it's
directly or indirectly by society that
um we shouldn't it's not just
to forgive someone who if they were if
that person was if they wronged you in
some way
then in some how we're somehow on some
level we're condoning it
or sanctioning it or we're saying that
it's okay what they did by forgiving
them
um and it's that like faulty or that
illusory
kind of perspective on it that
i think causes us to hold that hurt and
hold that pain because
once it's happened there's actually no
there's no virtue
i mean there's there's virtue in getting
the lesson and evolving in your
awareness so that it doesn't happen
again but there's no virtue in holding
on
to it and you really see like the beauty
of actually letting it go and
the alpha states that you start to
experience as you like clear all of
these resentments just gets really
really powerful there's there's no
beauty
in holding on to resentment there's no
virtue
in holding on to resentment that's a
great way to put it there's no
moral excellence in holding on to
resentment no
yeah because it it's it really what you
see it's it's in it's
it's in your field it's in your etheric
body it's in your psyche
it's it's in your physical body like
you're actually contracting around that
resentment
and um i think the buddha said it's like
um
it's basically like trying to throw a
hot coal at someone else like you're the
one that gets
you're the one that gets burned and so
by holding on to resentment we hurt
ourselves way more than we
we think that we're somehow punishing
the other person but it's
it's ignorance like we are punishing
ourselves by actually holding on to that
resentment so
that's great the hot coal yeah that's
true just burn yourself yeah
yeah like trying to throw a hot call at
somebody um
so on the neurofeedback level um
yeah on the way so biopsychonaut cyber
not
spiocybernaut yeah biocybernaut
so the
the biocybernaut program sounds like
there's a a quite
uh intricate
system of taking in the biometrics of
the body
and then kind of helping the
individual get nudged towards letting go
of the resentment
towards those alpha states
and and then there's the scores that
flashes so yeah you know there's the
feedback that you're getting
yeah so just to paint a picture also
because neurofeedback is essentially
like a mirror for your brain so
neurofeedback
we don't you know normally we'd actually
i think most people don't we don't know
what our brain is doing
especially on a brain wave level we we
you know definitely don't know and
so what mir neurofeedback does is give
you some sort of feedback and sometimes
it can be visual but
um a lot of it especially what i've done
is more auditory
where you're getting a sound depending
on if you're producing more of that
brain wave and so
it's kind of like becomes a candy for
the mind like a reward system
where it's like the brain sees oh if i
produce more alpha
i will get more of this sound and then
it starts to self
like it kicks in the brain's kind of
self-learning
um capacity where then it's like oh more
alpha more sound more alpha more sound
and then it just starts to
iterate and iterate and biocybernaut had
these kind of organ-like tones that were
really
pretty sounding and they're all in these
surround speakers in a room so
as you started to do that you would just
hear this like almost like a
organ orchestra play and you would get
more and more sound
and it would be this very rewarding
thing to think oh my god all of a sudden
i'm hearing all of these
these tones and if i forgive and i let
go something i'll get even more tones
yes yes
so it's rewarding you along the way for
yes
so this is this is very interesting so
it's as though within the
within
what we call our
chapter six and high level perception
the ai coach
that
here in this in this graphic
the idea is that you're not only
getting the feedback of the
biometrics and the psychometrics and
the fusion of the connectomix which is
the neuro
and then the ekg in the microbiome and
the metabolomics
and that you're actually getting
the small rewards just like kind of the
reinforcement learning agents in their
environments getting the small rewards
and then
if you're hearing you know the tiny bit
more and more of the
symphony let's say as the yeah you're
hearing more and more of it and you're
like
whoa and you're getting the higher and
higher
states of existence you know you it's a
good it's a good way to
to potentially get the get people to tap
into what
you know christ consciousness or buddha
consciousness or lots of confucius
consciousness
are and what does it mean to reside in
the dao
or what does it mean for atman and
brahman to be one or what does it mean
for
i and my father to be one and
what does it mean to have the absolute
highest moral
or ethical states of being
and how can i get those little rewards
along the way that kind of make me
baseline
this this leads into that point that you
brought up when
when you came which was that we have
these
we all we a lot of us have experienced
the atrophy that occurs when when we
either work out or we can't you know
after we run
you learn how to run half a marathon but
then you know maybe a year later
you have to kind of work your way back
up to a half marathon again
and so with states of consciousness
it does feel like there are times that
we do
kind of atrophy a little bit with the
eruptions that may happen but really
the i think the core essence of it is
correct where you and i were
talking before we started which is that
once you sort of re-baseline
and in this case it looks like
you know it's something like this you
know once you re-baseline
from you know one-dimensional thinking
on that left side of the bell curve and
you move yourself maybe
towards the center into more
multi-dimensional
thinking you know you're taking multiple
variables
into account it's not a binary thing
it's a multiple variables we're
analyzing the complexity
you know maybe you're starting to feel a
little bit more
like maybe you've actually read the data
chain or maybe you've read the old
testament or maybe you've sat
at an advice of it on to retreat etc and
you begin
sort of starting to when you look at
another you're actually
seeing that self and that
then things really start shifting so
that re-baselining
it's basically like you can't actually
go back
like there's no going like i can't see
things in one variable anymore
everything is multivariate everything is
nuanced now
everything every time that i look at
another person i see a
complex soul fusion of their roots
and their fruits and their in their
present moment
and so it's a that hot upgrading your
perception
you can't go back yes yeah yeah
you're right and in neurofeedback
there's
you're building literally building new
neural pathways and establishing new
circuitry
and it's not just i think we focus a lot
on with neurofeedback on the brain but
it's really the entire nervous system
it's the body it's even the bio field
um i think one of the the things that i
started to discover
as i would like in my second
neurofeedback intensive for example is
like
i picked up so there was no loss even
though i didn't do it for six months i
didn't pick up you know i didn't do a
single second of neurofeedback
um but in the second one in particular
i really started to see how much it was
beyond the brain and it really was about
the spine and the nervous system and so
i was
starting to be able to like use current
in my spine to move
move energy to my brain and then
modulate it and then actually
in biocybernate they have those two
minute periods so then i could just know
that i could rise
the energy to my brain expand kind of
infinitely in all directions
and feel which is which drives a lot of
alpha and then
um that energy in the spine could
actually hold that state perpetually
like
it wouldn't um it wouldn't regress or go
back
or fluctuate in the same way and so um
yeah there it's it's interesting that
what you're saying and and
um all the everything you're saying
about hlp
you know applies to inside the brain the
nervous system
the the field the biofield the field
that we're in the
shared field that we're in right now the
more that you access the field
um it's hard for that access to go away
it just yeah it's it becomes part of
there's pathways that open
yes that don't close yes
yeah it's so eloquent love that
love that
and they're some of my favorite
experiences are those where i'm just
re-baselining myself
closer and closer towards infinity
eternity
closer and closer towards that infinite
consciousness
i love that you know once once the
journey to
god ends the journey in god begins
you know that rupert's spirit is so good
i love him adore him that's such a good
one
and once you know what does residing in
god or
endow or realizing that brahman or one
what does that
what does that begin looking like well
it's at
you know just at a at an entire like
in a sense that the the vehicle itself
becomes just an antenna like just this
receiving station for that frequency of
of god
of bliss joy peace expanding outward
toward that infinite consciousness it's
it's a
man it it's like it's like being in a
it's like being in a ferrari and
versus being in a model t really yeah
it is yeah yeah and now we're adding all
of the
to continue on the car analogy you know
we're adding so many
sensors and data points on the dashboard
now yes and so now when you have your ai
coach you have this
visualization when when we're
it's probably a good time to get into
some of the the visualizations but now
that you have those
we're really able more and more to gain
insight into
you know well now we have a tire
pressure sensor well
you know now we have that ability to
have a
uh an eeg and and actually we're gonna
show
um sensei
sensei sensei is one of them that is
that's actually doing it in gamma
actually before we i want to show this
this is going to be important first
let's show
all right so
this is probably
this is probably okay for now i mean
there's
there's so many of these on the internet
but but just generally speaking when we
talk about brain waves
we're talking about at the lowest at
what is it somewhere it's uh it's only a
couple
hertz it's less than one hertz right
yeah there's the delta delta
delta's uh one to three typically i mean
below delta they call it like slow in
for low or slow cortical but
really it's yeah it's all delta and
delta yeah is typically associated with
sleep
um but delta also can be associated with
spiritual awakening kundalini
can activate a lot of delta in the
waking state and delta is really
um even some people believe that certain
kind of mystical superpowers like
ability to alter reality could be
associated with high degrees of waking
waking delta so it's a really
interesting brainwave but
um yeah that's the slowest one that we
look at typically
okay and then we go up from there to
theta and then to alpha and then
beta and then gamma and
it's interesting seeing the
the seven chakras on the left in this
one actually
it's kind of interesting yeah it is
interesting i know you should look at
that but it's interesting that
gamma is at the top and gamma definitely
in my experience
part of how i modulate gamma is by
moving
energy through the crown so um gamma
definitely seems to be crown
dependent and and delta i would say to
like the energy at the base of the spine
the more that's activated the more delta
you can produce um so
yeah it's interesting i think it's
accurate yeah
and this is um
this is an important aspect to that idea
of ai coach that when you have
the in this sense this would be kind of
like the the biometric portion of that
ai coach
that you need um and specifically
this is usually eeg is what shows us
uh the the range of
delta to gamma and you want on eeg you
want
more channels usually sure to be able to
give you more data points
where it's being measured from and it's
complex because you have to do the
the fourier transform for digital signal
processing
and then that makes it more that's a big
challenge but there are algorithms there
are very smart people that made
algorithms that enable
those transforms of the data to happen
and then you're able to
sort of see it visually as something
that's actually that you can understand
and then you can get the neural feedback
in the sense of slowly
working yourself into more awaken states
now is it
now this is this is a little strange for
you know we have these
we have these images that we're going to
show from your
these are specifically from your uh
trials
and that
i i wish it was so simple as that we
could just be like
you want to move from here to here right
but it's not like that
no interesting so yeah so i guess
tell us like what why it's not like that
and
and what i mean because it's it's
interesting because we talk about moving
from egoic
consciousness to unity consciousness or
symphonic consciousness where you feel
the unity and your unique artist
contributions
right kind of thing but
that's that's a v that seems very clear
the direction of that but with
it's not like we're going from delta to
gamma
they're used for different things
exactly okay so yeah let's unpack that
yeah they yeah different different um
they're really a really good metaphor
is like the gears of a car right like
there are certain times where you want
to be in
in one gear and there's other times
where you want to be in another gear
there's if you're wanting to experience
like the oneness of all
creation in the universe then like you
could shift into
the high gear of gamma and you're you're
like it's like you're on a rocket ship
through the cosmos and yeah but you
don't necessarily want to be there all
the time i mean
i think certain masters get to that
point like i mentioned we mentioned
ramana maharshi where
he had a massive awakening and i think
you get to a certain level of samadhi
where
you're kind of perpetually in yes in
that
and even then though i still think he
can turn up like when you when you
read about like stories where he gave
people darshan which is like the
the look of the guru that blesses
someone yes that like he could enlighten
someone just with his
his look and there's reports that like
he would actually his
everything would still and everything
would cause like there would be
something that changes in him and in the
person like
the person would have a massively like
mystical experience so
i love that i love that i love i love tr
i love trying to do that as much as i
can with
other people you know slowing things
down
to that level and then delivering
that sort of transmission
unconditional love
and then when people look back and when
they
like you said they are expressing that
they've undergone
some sort of mystical experience in that
short bit of time
like yeah that should be a goal yeah
yeah
we have that capacity yeah yeah and so
that's like one gear
but um there's times when it's
appropriate like where
you might want to do some deeper kind of
healing of your unconscious and that's
for that that was where theta would be
really good or
maybe you want to manifest something and
so you activate more delta
as you're visualizing something that you
want to manifest or
um you're expressing joy or gratitude or
love and you want to be in an alpha or
we talked about smr
which is like between alpha and beta
where
it's more like the flow state like if
you're actually doing
an activity like a sport where you need
to be super alert but you also need to
be kind of in a more of a zone
that's not really thinking there's no
mental chatter that would be like smr
so these are just gears that as you kind
of master
neurofeedback more and more you can
shift your brain intentionally
into the right gear for what you want at
that moment
yeah that's that's a good way to put it
these gears to shift into
so it it could be in a sense as though
there's a
there's there's more of a maybe a
like there is a binary shift into a gear
but then there's also a synthetic
blend between gears yeah and you're
never just accessing one brain wave at
one time right there's it's always like
it's always a sandwich or composition of
a variety of waves too
and that's going to vary that's why it's
really i think one of the dangers of
getting too obsessed with numbers and
and all this even and i've been
i've done this myself because of
especially because of how the numbers
that i've been able to experience
that it doesn't it you know one person's
amplitude on a brain wave
like a gamma like and i've actually seen
this like i could have 50 millivolts of
amplitude on gamma which is which is
like an almost
you know shouldn't barely be alive kind
of amplitude but then
someone else for them if they go they go
more above their baseline like they
could have a more ecstatic experience
and a more spiritual experience than i
would at mine and so it's
we all have kind of different
propensities and it's very
very complex it's not cut and try like
cut and dry like oh
this much more amplitude or coherence or
whatever is better than this
coherence is generally a better metric
than amplitude because
coherence and or synchrony is another
word
yes that speaks more to the balance
versus dissonance
yes you definitely don't want dissonance
you want coherence
yeah exactly higher coherence or higher
synchrony is is almost
always better higher amplitude sometimes
is it just means there's a little bit
more of like voltage in the system but
it doesn't necessarily mean that it's
like more of a mystical or
profound experience
yeah the the qualia research institute
team
um the andres gomez nielsen and
mike johnson and those guys we've had
them on the program a lot and
we love their symmetry theory of valence
the more symmetrical the more coherent
the greater states of valence better
imbalances
and that's a super interesting idea in
the space
um yeah you really want that with the
brain and and really that's one of the
biggest benefits of gamma
um training and accessing gamma more and
more
to the extent that the person can handle
it we can talk more about that but
um gamma unifies the brain i mean it's
it is
it's it's connected to unity
consciousness it's connected to kind of
almost like
genius level insight that's almost
pulling something from the cosmos and so
yes the more gamma that's accessed the
more the overall brain becomes coherent
and you see this like as i started to
unlock gamma
all of my synchrony and coherence of all
my waves went up
yeah um and like the the brain map
became just much more clear
yes and organized and healthy so gamma
is like this master synchronizer and
organizer
that you really want to access as much
as possible if you you know yeah again
to the extent that you've built the
right foundation
yes because there's a lot of energy in
gamma that
if your foundation is weaker it can make
you feel
a little bit imbalanced or crazy because
it's like running a lot of um
it would be like uh flooring a really
fast car but like the
the alignment of the car is really off
and then
everything internally gets more messed
up because of all that power right so
it's like before you access that amount
of power you really want to make sure
everything is aligned
yes foundation yeah yes yes
it has become more evident
as well to me that as i've
re-baselined more to these higher states
of being that
it feels like a
a stronger connection a stronger
immersion
in that dour in that god on a
moment-to-moment basis
and that then
from there everything else
seems to
channel itself into place accordingly to
be the highest
and it's it's hard it's not like every
day
is absolutely you know that's why the
whole the whole process of enlightenment
is a
never-ending process of constant growth
we're always uh
in process in progress and
but it definitely would be helpful to
have more
neurofeedback to have more
of the data visualization on a
moment-to-moment basis
you know and that i mean like this is a
big reason why
i chose out of
out of everything that i could have
chose to put
in that you know right there in that in
that bottom
left corner where you did you do the
data fusion
and then you see what you know the peak
performance level is
i literally wrote current elevated
cortisol
right and then your recommendation
exercise and so
that there's so many different
that that's probably the most common
though the most common way to feel
yourself in a sense
drop out of more of like a bliss or a
flow
or god state of consciousness is usually
when there
it feels like there's some sort of
dissonance happening some sort of stress
is happening
some sort of uh victim consciousness is
happening
maybe it's resentment maybe it's ego
maybe it's all these different
words that are describing somewhat
similar phenomenons
and that those phenomenological states
to basically get
a thing like a notification you know
that that sort of pavlovian style
um mechanism that that draws you further
away from that and more
back towards where you were towards that
highest
is uh is it's a really beautiful
beautiful and we we have to visualize
we have to visualize the data um
let's go through some of the sure some
of the graphics
um so
okay so the first graphic we're gonna go
through is the
controlled gamma
yeah and basically the story behind
that is um you know gamma's the black
line
um when i after i did the biocybernaut
trainings i went over to
one that was created by dave asprey
called 40 years of zen
which was allowed more flexibility in
training different waves and i realized
that
um a lot of the alpha that i was
producing in biocybernet was actually
being driven by
more by gamma because gamma and alpha
are related all these brainwaves are
interrelated
and so um all of a sudden it was like
wow i on
i felt like i'd um yeah unlock this and
i could and i could start to
using again the energy in the spinal
cord and actually
um feeling that the energy moved through
the top of the crown
um i would uh i developed the ability
basically to control how much am
gamma amplitude i could produce and then
it just kept going up and up and up
until it became
you know um higher than they had
at least they had seen before i'm sure
there's been higher but um
it was and um what's interesting is like
the
it was controlled in the beginning i
mean it was controlled but it was more
spiky
in the earlier times but then it became
more organized and more
um consistent and becomes more efficient
over time so then
that's another thing like we were saying
about amplitude high amplitude is not
always desired if if it's not efficient
like if
it was taking me a lot of energy to
produce that much gamma and so kind of
as i progressed
the amplitude has dropped
[Music]
when i generally train because i don't
need to produce
that much and i can actually do it much
more effortlessly
and still be in a mystical um
state and so um yeah that's just an
example and
um really i think for anybody that wants
to produce gamma at home that doesn't
have a neurofeedback i think
um really just um feeling breathing into
this you know breathing
with the whole body from the the feet
to the crown and actually feeling
current to the best of your ability from
the base of your spine
move up through your crown that will
almost always produce more
gamma for anybody that wants to to do it
um
and so slow down and
practice that yes
another thing that um connects kind of
all the brain waves but i think
especially alpha
and gamma um which you i thought it was
really interesting when you said you you
developed like a
kind of a notification system when
you're in a dissonant state
one of the things that i've observed a
lot is that like
thinking i i saw this in biocybernaut
thinking
generally suppresses alpha same and same
with gamma
anytime there's chatter or another
thinking or that you're engaging with
thinking
those waves will go down but when you're
in a state of feeling
they go up and what's interesting is
that i've i've been pondering this more
and more lately like thinking is always
and i'm not the first person to say this
krishnamurti and a lot of other people
said this
no thinking is rooted in the past like
thinking is inherently rooted in the
past because there's always
a memory component of thinking you can't
think
without some dimension of memory but
feeling is actually always in the
present
right you're actually you're active if
you're actively feeling you're in the
present moment
um so one of the best ways to shift
yourself
out of the chatter and past rooted
thinking mindset
that is is lower energy and that's
quantified lower energy on like a
neurofeedback eeg and everything is that
is to just feel as intentionally as
possible and
where the kind of the healing or the
inner work comes in is that when you
really open up the floodgates of feeling
you feel everything and a lot of the
things that you you didn't feel before
or that you were resisting feeling
before or that you buried
those start arising kind of like
pandora's box
and then you've got to feel through
everything that arises and feel beyond
everything that arises
and then if you succeeded that your
capacity for feeling kind of
extends out into the cosmic domain or
the
and that's when things become mystical
but
it's through feeling it's not through
it's not through thinking or any kind of
other
manipulation really pure feeling is is
is really the ultimate practice
this is this is very on point with what
has been discussed for
a long time like you were indicating and
that
the
einstein quote that i just
saw yesterday about intuition
being the highest
there's a lot of now
scientists and
other highly respected physicalists
that are that are
affirming some of the spiritual
traditions
wisdoms around intuition and around
feeling
and what that means to
also the relationship between the
masculine and the feminine
as well which is very interesting
and that
there may be a also a
some sort of a synthesis in the sense of
the reality that we are in
given it being
quantum mechanical and given there being
observers that make
decisions in the reality
given that there is a
a
intuitive channeling if you will of what
may be
the highest possible
decision does that does that
feel as though there's a
that there's a sort of surrender to a
intuitive channeling that occurs that
the thinking
almost completely
silences itself or does it rise and
blend
and is it kind of like those gears of
the of the vehicle how is that how does
that
look for you anthony yeah i mean
i would say first of all uh when i talk
about feeling it's not just i mean of
course
you know there's internal feeling but
i'm talking also
would i practice in a neurofeedback
context and
meditation and what i've been learning
and studying is more of like
feeling it's a process of really feeling
beyond so it's feeling
feeling through the body but but feeling
beyond the body and feeling
everything so it's like you're feeling
out into
into space and you're it's a much more
expansive kind of
manner of feeling yes and that opens um
what happens is as that that feeling
capacity expands um
obstructions that energetic obstructions
like things that are getting in the way
of the channel of feeling that you're
talking about
those will arise but then those will be
you feel beyond those and then those
they burn up like um you could call it
karma you could call it
blockage you could call it trauma
whatever you want to do like if you just
keep
acknowledging whatever arises but then
continue to not get fixed on it and just
to keep feeling beyond it
yes um that feeling capacity
and i think that's the enlightened the
enlightened state is basically a state
of infinite
feeling they're able to feel all of it
all of existence
yes as one but feeling is a muscle that
we have
to like we do have to work out and we
have to build and and most of us
and thinking and feeling are competitive
um to answer your questions so
um it's hard to feel fully if we're
engaged in
chatter but if we prioritize feeling
the thinking that the thinking dominance
that i think most of us suffer from
it starts to reduce and reduce and
reduce and reduce
and even thinking well the energy of
thinking because it's all energy
energy of thinking will begin to merge
with the energy of feeling
yes but it will kind of more just take
its rightful place
and thought will arise only as it's
needed not unnecessarily
yes and then you're able to just stay
perpetually in this
feeling of love bliss which is like
consciousness or reality itself yes
which is
um what masters like adidas and others
many others say
and that um yeah that kind of
it resolves it resolves a lot i think of
the issues of
of that thinking but we have to
i think we have to recognize that um
the kind of war that we're i don't
i don't love the war metaphor always
because it's like it implies a fight or
an enemy
yeah but there is a tug there's kind of
a we're kind of perpetually in a tug of
war
of like the mind pulling us into kind of
this contracted obsessive um
small energetically kind of you know
always spinning always chasing always
running
suffering versus the the feeling
state of the heart which is which is the
opposite of that and that's a different
it's a different awareness and it's a
different energy and a different
attention and the more we prioritize the
feeling and keep giving energy to
feeling
as a practice moment to moment and um as
an intensified practice and
neurofeedback
the the faster we awaken
so we'll get to these
the other examples this is so juicy that
there's just so much
so much here so the
the ultimate states of being
feel the whole and by the whole we mean
everything we mean holism
everything god
ultimate states feel all of existence
feel all of existence not
think feel all of existence yes
and then once we sort of re-baseline
ourselves
more and more to feeling all of
existence feeling the whole
right the way that we sort of
have been perpetually trying to
help bring it to people's
consciousness is through the the magic
trick
graphic right of chapter
eight because you don't just
you don't just exist in your
little square box around your head but
you
exist as part of this entire process
from big bang
until you contemplating what reality is
and so to to see it at that whole level
and that this is just one song one
universe
and that we may in fact be
uh there's many more
that are that consciousness is exploring
infinity so
the more that we baseline ourselves
to feeling
the unity feeling the whole the more
that we
would you say become
surrender to the right thought coming
when it comes
yes okay exactly there's an efficiency i
think of thought where
we're not thinking i think most of our
thoughts that we tend to think
are not really they don't serve us
they're just chatter or they're
you know negative thoughts or whatever
they are they're i'm worried
um and yeah i think in the enlightened
state
which i'm not there yet but i'm i think
i see a progression or i see kind of a
pathway towards me too
where um there's less and less of that
sort of thinking
and it just there's more and more space
between thoughts yes
and there's more feeling um capacity
that's building and
and um the ability to be in that feeling
kind of heart feeling state more
perpetually and then
um thought yeah i mean
another way to look at it um the the
chiropractor that i mentioned donnie
epstein that won the development
by analysis he said that um
the thoughts that we have like
especially the
the ones that we're talking about in
particular they're not they're not
really ours
they're actually just a reflection of
the level of energy that we're accessing
through the field
and that particular moment yeah
interesting and so
if you raise your ad if you actually
raise your access to the field and raise
your energy
the thoughts immediately change yes
that's why it's so silly
to even interact with our thoughts most
of the time
because um it's like a kind of like a
dog chasing its tail
right like you're not going to get
you're just going to go around in a
circle but if you actually
raise your actual your level of energy
in that moment and access more of the
field
that and and how you do that is through
feeling
that ex exercising that feeling capacity
yeah
energy goes up and the thoughts
immediately change and then the thoughts
that you had a moment ago were no longer
they're no longer
even there anymore so of course they're
not a problem yeah
yeah so there's the
the box
i'm a fan of explaining it with through
the graphic here
on identity and porosity that if
if you're in the box on the right
and you're like the dog chasing its tail
with thought
versus if you're like on the left where
you have this
extremely high level of porosity
like you're basically a perforated
beingness with existence
um your
level of
energetic connection to
what is occurring is at higher levels
and there like you said there's more
space between thoughts that's a really
important one
actually you know that's probably one of
the most
famous ones of buddhism is that you
spend less time reacting and more time
just cognizing just being present rather
than
rather than reacting and less time
dwelling in that
that aversion or craving
and there's just more just being um
and then when you re-baseline away from
just that
incessant dog chasing its tail you're
accessing higher
levels of energy the higher levels of
energy that you're accessing the more
and more over time that the right
thoughts are coming the ones that serve
the highest are coming
so then is it to you is it then
a is it a co-creative relationship
though
so that that the
that this that the individual
consciousness that that
individual the seemingly
individual the nerve ending if you will
of the
of the hole that
that that that nerve ending has a
has a relationship of choice
it has a relationship of seeing the
the incessant thought versus seeing the
the higher states of being where it is
more intuitive more
feeling more expansive is you you
yeah is it yeah there's still a choice
yeah yeah
i think so there's and there's the level
of wiz i think there's a
inherent wisdom in that awareness at
that stage where it's like
it just sees it stays the thought
for what it is and and there's no
identification
with that thought there's usually the
problem with there's no problem with
thought
i it's the identification with the
thought that usually gets us in trouble
because it takes us down that rabbit
hole or
to you know the tail the dog chasing its
tail kind of metaphor where
as soon as we think the thought is mine
and then it's a problem and then i've
got to do something and i've got to fix
it then you're sucked in and then you're
just going around and around in circles
but
um to your point about choice if you
actually see it for what it is and that
it's not really yours
then there's a choice to not give it any
attention
yeah and to direct attention elsewhere
that's more expansive yeah and in the in
the direction of awakening
aha okay so then once one gets
into greater and greater states of
feeling the whole and being immersed in
that process
intuitive thought rather than the
dog chasing its tail that
when one is asked from a
non-dual state of experience
if they would prefer coffee or tea
what occurs i mean
it's interesting because you read these
stories um i mean i'm not at that at
that stage but you read these stories
about masters have completely
transcended their ego and
they still have i don't know they
somehow still manage to have preferences
and to make choices
and to do different you know and you
know there's um
um you know i forget i can't i can never
say his name but he smoked a lot of
cigarettes or like
you know ramana maharshi you know he
would
have his idiosyncrasies like there's
still or every
every spiritual master i think i think
some element of the personality
um you know like hawkins
he talks about we're all kind of karmic
wind-up toys right like you can become
awakened but that wind-up toy is still
going to kind of like do its
ah it's things it's in the world it's
funny
that's really funny yeah so even after
you're enlightened like the
and you've transcended kind of karma in
the sense of birth and death like where
you still have a human body that brain
that is gonna have its tendencies
yeah you have four and a half billion
years of evolutionary lineage
inside of you and on a planetary level
and you know three and a half billion on
a
cellular evolutionary level and that
there's so much of that sort of
a priori filtration that's been built up
through that
evolutionary lens of of of
of a decision towards some sort of of a
of a reward function and all of this
wind-up
toy habits and behaviors and
the familial epigenetics and everything
that's just been like
handed to you lineage-wise and so
it's a wind-up toy even that's funny
that's a really good way to put it
even even if you're obtaining non-dual
states
there's still some wind-up toy action
yeah yeah
yeah still you're still getting that
yeah
wow
that's uh that's probably one of my
favorite
topics on consciousness is that
non-duality is beautiful
and it reminds me a lot of the person
that attains some sort of spiritual
ascent
on a mountaintop and then what i
hypothesize
can potentially be beyond that is
the non-duality with the
symphonic so the symphony is the
non-duality but the individual artist
the nerve endings
inside of that symphony are playing
different wind-up
melodies and instruments and things like
that and so
that's when the that's when the master
that went on the spiritual ascent of the
mountain
and attained some non-dual gnosis of the
symphony
ends up coming down to the metro
to the civilization and anchoring the
wisdoms
in the beingness of everything that is
happening so that there is this
butterfly effect that happens
to others that that we were mentioning
earlier when you can
slow things down to that level it's
where you can
package that tiny bit of
unconditional love that god that someone
else feels
and then they have a spiritual
experience a mystic experience that they
take with them everywhere they go and
what not afterward so
i think i
feel that
there's a co-creative process with the
melody that i play in the instrument
that i play do you feel that way
yeah yeah i love that um i saw that in
another one of your
your podcasts and i think it's a it's an
amazing metaphor because like you said
even when you become enlightened
you're still an instrument in this
greater
whole like you have some element as long
as you're in a body you have some
element of into
individuality right that is that
instrumentation
and then you recognize i think one of
the things though that the trademarks of
enlightenment is that you
can see the instrument the unique
instrument that everyone else
in existence is playing and you respect
that and you honor that and you
you have reference for that so there's
no better
and or worse or good or bad everyone is
playing this you know kind of
simultaneously playing an instrument yes
that
is part of this grand song of existence
yeah the the way that we've been talking
about it's
exact that's so spot-on the way that
we've been talking about it is that
there's this
there is this within the symphony
there's a
there's a a beauty to feeling the whole
of the symphony
and just holding that and being
in it you know that's the master
residing in the dao as laozi would say
that is that and that
when you reside there then that's where
the whole
way phenomenon occurs as well the
effortless action phenomenon occurs
where
everything that you do is from that
perspective
and so there is no choice of of
malevolence that that occurs because
everything is from that
gnosis that knowing of the whole of the
other
is the self and that we have um
that as a foundational pillar point
and yet there's also a
within this within the symphony there's
also
not only that truth that the whole
symphony is the truth and that the
symphony is occurring and that there's
that truth that
that truth that kind of transcends the
yin yang but then the yin yang itself
is still happening which is you see
somebody that is
you know still killing somebody else or
violence
violent or tyrannical or dictatorial or
blah blah blah and that all of those
examples that are
far left on the bell curve on the
evolution of consciousness that are
still
malevolent that those are bad
and so that's in the yin yang vision of
it is that those are bad we are moving
away from those towards the good which
is the bliss joy love maximizing
potential of everybody
but then the truth is that it's all that
symphony that's unfolding and so yeah
we uh we have we just did that one again
like two nights ago
that that graphic yeah it's funny i
should start keeping the
the most recent show graphics more more
near me so i can just pull them up
instead of drawing them
every single time because i've moved it
away
so yeah so that is is probably
even even if you get let's say even if
you get
to your feelings of
infinity unity holism you get to those
feelings and then you
intuitively
feel that thought arise of that you
prefer the tea or the coffee in
the wind-up toy or that the
or that you know that
you get the the message if you would
like to go to this event and you
you know you get the intuitive yes or no
you have do you have a a do you have a
preference for
how much of that is your
quote call your artist's choice
to you know to do some vibrato there or
or not i mean
um i would say that i have
less um
yeah i don't know i think i become less
attached to my likes and dislikes
i still have them though i think um and
um i get you know it's a progression and
i think you know
i think an enlightenment really like
they become minimized but they're still
even then they
we just talked about they they exist so
yeah i mean i think though
noticing the intensity of like one of
the signs of spiritual progress would be
to notice
um a reduction like in the intensity of
preference
uh
yes because because if your state is
if your state is kind of um if you're in
a natural state of joy
then like getting your preference or not
getting your preference isn't that going
to necessarily
yes give you any more joy than you
already are right then you
already have so most people are
operating
not from a baseline level of joy under
the assumption that if they get their
preference
they will get more joy and if they don't
get their preference then they'll
less joy less joy right so that's i
think that's the shift that starts to
occur
yeah that's a good point and then i
would also asterisk that with
if on one of the choices is the
suffering of
actually having violence occur against
you or on the other side it's not having
a baseball bat swinging against my knee
or whatever
yeah yeah that's yeah that's natural
yeah yeah but tea or coffee or going to
an event or not yes
uh there's not as much yeah it's i'm
baseline joy period yeah
yeah that type of mentality yeah and
um and yeah i think i think that's not
something we can talk ourselves into
and that's one of the things i think
that i think like a lot of positive
thinking in that movement
it doesn't um i think it's it's kind of
a sort of
reprogramming that can be helpful for
people but i think one of the things
that you see
in um neurofeedback and in gamma
training in particular is like
there is this baseline level of joy that
just arises in high gamma
that then as you're able to maintain
gamma effortlessly like
that baseline state of joy that is
is and is energetic
and is like it's it's just part of your
nature that's
that's what i would notice a lot in my
pika gamma experience is that like
this ecstatic joy or love is like this
is actually my real
like who i thought i was is not who i am
and this ecstatic just being is my real
nature and therefore
um but like it's not something that
yeah again you can't positive think your
way to that
it's an energetic um alchemy and kind of
a transformation that has to occur
on a nervous system level and yes
etheric
brain neurological like all these
different levels and systems that are
interrelated i think
um and that's again the advantage of
this kind of work and why i'm such a
so passionate about getting it out to
more people and sharing it yes yes
yeah the gnosis must be
anchored in the vehicle and
it must be anchored in the heart and it
must be
not kept in the box inside of the head
and that
the more that we do that the more that
it actually
firmly becomes our essence
our smell our of our flower
um i want us to do as we get into the
other two images um
what i what i want us to do quick is i
want us to
do um another small
um quick breakdown will you
um will you run us through um we gave we
did
we did gamma yeah and in in gamma we
talked a lot about that
peak we talked a lot about that
that's that god or unity state that type
of state
and then we talked in this sort of
a lot of the time we hear some something
like you said a flow
state and that's a between an alpha and
a
in a beta and a beta and so
so then you have this sort of
flow state and then you have a
what would be another common what is a
like what is the the common
you know or is there a common state
of when i'm doing a car
driving or a dish washing or a
um you know is that is there a common
and and if so
can i make that gamma can i be washing
my dishes
and feel god while i'm washing my dishes
you know that type of thing many
many artists have tried you know making
that in their artwork and expressing
that in the most mundane thing you can
feel unity
yeah yeah i think generally people spend
you know 90 of or more you know like a
huge amount of the
i don't know the exact stat but they
spend a lot of their time too much time
in beta which is more like fight or
flight
or just more like baseline level of kind
of
wakefulness um but there's nothing
particularly energized or special about
it it's just like you said it's
um and to your yeah to your point
yes um like in the in terms of studies
like on monks
um you can get to the point where you
can be high in higher
gamma kind of throughout the day and and
functional even in sleep
and um yeah and so you can be more in
that like the portal can be basically
open all all the time amen
yeah yeah so yeah it is possible
but um i think there's also an evolution
to that because
um as i've gone really deeper and deeper
into i mean as you accelerate gamma um
training there's a lot of um
it's like running a lot more current
than through a a wire than the wire can
initially handle
and so you'll get a lot of shaking like
shaking in your hands shaking in your
limbs shaking your spine your head
because it's almost like it's the energy
is basically opening up these new
pathways and it's it's almost like
plowing through any blockages or
obstruction and basically like widening
the nerves
so that it can handle this increased
energy and circuitry
and so um you don't want to
you kind of have to like go do that
process a little bit slower because
you can overwhelm your system if you're
just like for you know you won't want to
be in that state all day long you might
fry out your nervous system will fry out
or you might have anxiety or something
so
you have to kind of ease your way into
opening and then i think but eventually
as all that circuitry is open
and it's no longer an effort for you to
be running that much current
it's no longer shaking your system and
trump you know
difficult on your system then i think
that possibility exists where you can
just be
in the awakened state all the time yes
yes
yeah beautiful so we're looking at what
could be something
like if we were to visualize the
the dashboards of our
biometric psychometrics the big data
fusion
that out of the 8 billion of us or so
that the
most of us are spending
time in beta states
of could we say some sort of a
an more
autopilot style yes mode
absolutely yeah like i'm getting through
dishwashing so i can get to what will
hopefully bring me more joy
is that potentially description yeah and
it's kind of one mundane thing to the
next
one yeah dishwashing to tv to phone
to um email or whatever it happens to be
but there's not yeah there's not there's
not a lot of transcendental
access
and does it look a little bit like when
when beta begins experiencing like
you know how sometimes people say that
when you
like a grandparent
will have their heart melt a little bit
like a very especially like a grandpa
that has maybe been a little bit
like intense in life and then like his
son
or daughter has a child and so he gets a
great child yeah and you know like that
kind of brings them maybe from a more
like beta
into an alpha state so is that right
does it slow them down a little bit and
it brings them into that
yeah and that's a lot of um what's so
healing about um something like what we
experience it by a cyberknife i think is
a lot of the buildup of emotion and
resentment
um it keeps us in that in that beta like
excess beta state perpetually and we
never
because like the some of the slower
waves are very rejuvenating
on a deeper level and so um
but to access them we have to actually
clear
the the tension and the resentment and
those underlying unresolved emotions and
traumas that
are keeping us in that fight-or-flight
state because
you can meditate and i think it's of
course it's it's valuable to like
to do any sort of rely or just try to do
some kind of relaxation technique but
then
generally you'll kind of go back after
you you go through the relaxation
you'll go back to fight your default
fight or flight which is a reflection of
like what's unresolved
yes within so um for kind of more
permanent
access to these slower and more
rejuvenative states
that you know the work has to be done
yes yes
so would it be fair then to say that the
the transcendent states
beyond the moving from mundane to
mundane and beta
autopilot that would it be fair to say
something like
we simultaneously
slow
into more alpha in that that example
of you know when you get the baby
you know and you're like oh my gosh you
know i have so many people that have
just
slowed down due to that process which is
super interesting right that
transcendental
realization
and then we go even slower into theta
states maybe that's
when there is a profound realization of
the person that you're
falling in love with or that so there's
there's maybe there are these ways to
achieve these
slower states that are not even you know
maybe meditation
oriented but again meditation isn't
something we do it's what we
are again that's another rupert's fire
phrase right yeah
but but uh so there's a simultaneous in
a sense descent
that occurs with our slower
brainwave frequencies and then there's
also
an ascent beyond beta into the gamma
[Music]
so so and so then is that is that about
right that there is a
transcendent way below down and a
transcendent way up and what
yeah yeah yeah there is and i think um
that's something that
is hard to explain i don't know um
because i had a friend asked me about
that recently too
and it's um yeah it's weird that you can
be transcendent kind of on
both ends of the of the spectrum
um it's cool it's cool yeah i think and
sometimes too what happens is
you slow way down and then that um
that that super slow down ignites
kundalini and then that kind of goes
then it goes up to gamma and then gamma
gets accessed and then sometimes for
some people
um you can go more straight to gamma and
then the other ones the slower waves
will be brought
up so i think ultimately there's kind of
a merging of the top and the bottom yep
but like where you start i think it
depends on a person's kind of proclivity
and their
yes their tendencies and everything yeah
okay so let me let's put it this way
also
um
would it potentially be fair to say
something
like that
this most
baseline beta
is potentially where humans in
kind of enter into the portal of
awareness
like you know boom like you're in debate
you're in beta
state when you're you know your moment
moment-to-moment existence
of course it's different some people
become enlightened very young ages they
don't
even spend that much time a bit the
point being is
you enter into let's say the reality
and you're entering at beta let's say
and then from there then you can
go either way
from that which end up being kind of the
same thing
which is transcendent states of gamma or
of the alpha theta
deltas and deltas in a sense
are the ones that are typically talked
about with sleep and so
sleep is another sort of that you merge
into the ocean you know you
are unity consciousness in that ocean
that's another way of seeing it so
so okay so we you portal into reality
at beta and then from there you can you
know you have that
gamma actually the gamma to me is a very
to me it feels like it's a very
that god presence it can feel like it's
something that's that's a little bit
more higher frequency
but to me um it also does
feel a little bit delta with extreme
slow
yeah yeah you know this is very
interesting yeah there's i think there's
a really interesting like
unexplored um relationship between delta
and gamma
in the awakening process that i would
love to dive deeper in i've seen oh yeah
in my case for example i can put on
i can do gamma training and um
i will if i close my eyes like my gamma
will rise
my energy will rise through my spine the
to my crown and
that's just it's my default at this
moment but if i open my eyes
and actually do like an open-eyed
meditation
somehow even with the gamma feedback my
delta will spike
and some of what i showed you the the
delta chart that was like super high
where it was like off the chart that was
actually um
training in gamma so i had gamma
feedback
but my eyes were open and somehow the
energetic the
energy was different with my eyes open
and what was going on with my neurology
um and the meditation that i was doing
that was activating
and i think um in
i forget what they call it um like
ramana and other mystics have talked
about this and kundalini
you got the root and then it rises to
the crown and that's um
there there's like a a certain um term
for that
part is it like a taurus in a sense yeah
and exactly and yeah but but that energy
at the root has to rise to the crown
to for this like certain level of
realization and i think
even on this chart that you showed like
deltas at the root
and gammas at the crown so there is some
kind of connection between
delta and gamma coming together oh my
gosh we just should we just literally
just connect the circle basically
yeah that's kind of interesting it's
kind of interesting
it's like a circle being it's like a
line that
yeah we're folding into a circle yeah
yeah so and the transcendent is
potentially that delta or that game yeah
would you would you say that when you're
in a
more um
if you're if you're if you're feeling
some sort of more
divine states
doing what is seemingly mundane
activities
is that the more of a descent into like
alpha and theta
or is that more of an ascendant to the
gamma
um i would say it's probably
i i mean i think for most people gamma
is not going to be functional
in terms of being in the world like
interesting yeah so it's going to be
more of the slower i think
more people are going to be able to
function i see in a slower
very interesting because high gamma
before your nervous system is acclimated
to it is like
it's a little bit like having a seizure
yeah
oh yeah you're like this and then it it
normalizes
and and and it kind of like your your
nervous system is like oh this is not a
threat and then it comes and then that
the current moves
through more smoothly and the channel is
open and then
um you know you can access other
like in one of the charts that we were
looking at like like
i'm able to keep my gamma steady but not
at a level that's like
um too much shake or uncomfortable it's
like a high gamma but it's a sustainable
for me because of how
my system has evolved and then i'm
actually able to focus more on the heart
simultaneously which increases the alpha
interesting and so then sometimes my
alpha even would come above
gamma because i'm just like focusing on
this heart radiance and there's like
this ecstatic joy or love that's pouring
in
um while that kind of gamma state is
being held
yes yes so you can kind of start to kind
of merge
a lot of these states too where like
your delta is that your
delta's activated your alpha's feeling
and through your heart your gammas
you've got current coming through it's
like can get really trippy because
there's levels of sophistication that
are are
interesting so so we're never
experiencing just one
we're experiencing all five in different
dosages so okay let's go let's go look
at what i think was the one
were you just talking about the yeah
this one yeah that one so it's like
gamma
i mean it's a little bursty but it's
relatively steady in terms of like
how gamma is the black line all the way
across but then
the alpha is actually which is like the
heart
feeling is is is really high and spiking
very and those are that producing that
much alpha especially in the midst of
gamma is um you just feel like
ecstasy so how alpha is alpha is con
is known as the heart
yeah it's connected to yeah connected to
heart frequency
and so and just to look at this again
you're you're saying that the
um that so so delta theta
alpha beta and gamma are all
being represented in some quantities
all yes all at the same time yeah and so
in this case what what would be
what what are we saying about the
quantities in this case
is that what's do you know what the 12
and the 25
are that's unique to that system so it
doesn't
those are very high numbers but it's you
know they don't
translate into kind of universal um
yeah they don't they don't translate
into kind of a universal measurement
because every neurofeedback system
has its own its own system but in a
typical
a typical person if they were doing
really well might produce like
um five or ten uh mil
on that scale so that's like to go to 40
or
30 or 40 is is like really high it's
very high
um and i'm doing these actually too
typically in neurofeedback training is
like you're sitting in a chair but
as i got my system at home i started
doing it cross-legged basically so just
doing it in full
yes meditation posture
is it is it also fair to say that the
entirety of the consciousness moves
in a direction because it looks as
though the
as the alpha the out the alpha
the gamma and the beta are all moving
on a peak and they're all moving on the
trough yeah
yeah yeah exactly okay so they are
moving cohesively
yeah interesting okay but then there's
also
the scenarios where
you have
this and so this
yes this example this one doesn't this
one does not move
cohesively this is you know delta's
skyrocketed
it looks like someone's asleep yeah but
i'm i'm awake
yeah i'm doing wide awake so i'm i'm um
yeah and that was the meditation the
ramana maharshi
meditation that i told you where i would
just like gaze at the picture and feel
into his state and my delta would
skyrocket and um at first almost it was
so
high that i didn't think it was real but
i spoke to a doctor and he was like yeah
because it's the way that it's not
because sometimes you get noise in
neurofeedback or like um
artifacting like if you're moving or
there's something else going on blinking
too much
um but i i was like no i feel pretty
still and i checked with him and it was
true and so
um yeah but i think it's all what i
could describe in that experience was
just like a massive amount of like
spinal
activity and energy and then this
feeling
um yeah just the
the feeling into the state of a realized
i mean that's one of the most powerful
things that we can do
um that's another interesting technique
is to actually
um take a picture of any enlightened
being that you're drawn to
and actually just feel into their
um like through your heart through your
body through your nervous system
um feel into their state and like um
feel what that state is or feels like
and i think that
there's something really magical it's
like we're um
i don't know it's hard to put it into
words and it's gonna sound very woo-woo
but like we're given i think it's one of
the
the gifts that the divine gave to us and
through these living
realized beings is that their states
um are transmittable in person but not
only that but also through their voice
through their image
and so by actually meditating and
connecting with that and feeling into
that then um we have access
to those and those can begin to transfer
yes to us
yes you see that a lot in india like
there's a lot of devotion to
puja and to to deities and to pictures
of gurus and
and everything it's a it's a powerful
practice yeah
this is extremely spot on that
one of the most common ways to
sort of trigger yourself into
state is a feeling of unity is to have
that little shrine of your
preferred master that has attained
such incredible states prior to you and
that
it helps that process a lot and so
is this do now does this normally look
the same way as
with the high delta is that normally
what a sleep
you know looks like or what i mean i'd
be interested i don't know what sleep
would look like on this system so it's
hard for me to say
but um yeah i'm not sure how much yeah
delta would be above the other
waves and sleep that's a good question
what's up what's the system called
what's this one signet
yeah c-y-g-n-e-t c-y-g-n-e-t
and then is this online software that
you can just download
it requires a special amplifier that is
pretty pricey it's like
five six thousand dollars and you have
to yeah you have to be
um working with a practitioner basically
to
to access it so yeah it's not um
but we're democratizing yes and i guess
we can give the example
yes there's there's more accessible
neurofeedback technologies
coming so
okay so the the the existing
um one that people are really familiar
with is muse
um and that's only like 200 bucks or
something yeah
but that only has a couple channels on
it and
only you said alpha is the only thing
that it really measures
quite well yeah it doesn't yeah
it's it's just not um it's it's nowhere
approaching kind of clinical
level of any of anything really i mean i
think for some people just a calming
effect can be helpful
but yeah in terms of like really true
neurofeedback
there's just not enough channels there's
not the right feedback there's not the
the right level of sensitivity the
channel i think the placement even
though the channels are the electrodes
are the sensors are not
optimum um but yeah there's been a
dilemma in the neural feedback space
that like you either had to use these
really expensive professional systems or
these consumers
like kind of devices that didn't really
do anything but i am
really excited about this one that you
have yeah let's do it let's see
okay um sensei it won't be ready until
next year but i'm um i've had a lot of
dialogue with the company
um and their founders and they're
amazing people and
they've really cracked the code on
how to create professional grade
sensitivity and accuracy
including of gamma which is which is
very difficult to do
and to do it in a dry headset that
doesn't have any wires
so just for context for most people like
with neurofeedback you usually have to
put these electrodes on your head you
have to put kind of a gel that
it's like a glue um it's very sticky
it's hard to wash off it
sticks in your hair and um and that's
for conduction yeah it's conduction and
even placing those electrodes is a pain
and then taking them off
um and then you've got to have this
special laptop that has all of this
power
that amp you know has an amplifier it's
a whole ordeal it's not convenient at
all and so
yeah there's a reason why nobody does it
at home the pricing the inconvenience
but basically this device solves all of
that and lets you train
um gamma and then the other brain waves
too which you know muse only does like
alpha
but they'll do theta they can do delta
they can do smr they can do
um even other technologies hrv and
photobiomodulation yeah yeah
that will assist the brain and assist
the kind of the stability
and um yeah it's
and oh what we were talking about before
too is that um
it's adaptive so they're they're
building in um not only gamification
of their app and and like progressions
and programs into their sequence but
also
their um they'll have ai and machine
learning that will basically look
at your data that comes in and then
alter your program
so that you're training on the right
track for you so it's kind of like
personalization it's great to still have
a practitioner and nothing will take the
place of
a world-class practitioner but um in
order it's
it's it's the closest thing to having
guidance
and moving you along the track so um
yeah and it will be
um you just put it on you sync it to
your phone and you you get training
and you know it'll be below thousand
dollars i think below even seven or
eight hundred dollars so
and yeah it's um to make a device like
this that's so
far ahead of the market and where the
market's been um
definitely takes a lot of innovation and
production and everything so
it's um it's looking like towards the
end of next year but
i would recommend anybody goes to their
list because i think that they're going
to have a lot of
um they are going to have a lot of a lot
of interest and a lot of demand and you
can get updates by
joining their list i'm not um you know i
yeah i have nothing to promote here
today but i just i'm a big believer in
terms of
we've talked a lot about neurotech
neurofeedback but
a technology as technologies that can
transform humanity if we could get
millions of people doing
yes this foundational kind of training
and then progressing their way to gamma
and then doing gamma and doing these
programs and optimizing like we
you know a million people doing that
we'd have a different world because
that's right as humanity rate you know
individuals raise unconsciousness it's
exponential right like
through david hawkins he talks about
that one raise you know one person going
up 100 points and their level of
consciousness is like
counter balance is the negativity of
many many many more people like just
like one enlightened being can
counterbalance the
the negativity of hundreds of millions
if not a billion people
um and so all
a lot of the world that we're in right
now and the problems that we have are
just a reflection of the level of
consciousness
100 the masses and if yes a portion of
the
even just a small portion of the masses
rise in consciousness
we have a different world yes
yeah yeah reality is a hundred percent a
reflection of our consciousness
and the more awake we become the more
divine the social fabric becomes the
more
we all maximize our flourishing and we
move away from malevolence and violence
so
it's just a rep it's just a reflection
of our consciousness our level of
consciousness
and so the democratization of
neurofeedback
tools is paramount to elevate our
consciousness
it may be apparent i mean it's probably
very very high up it's probably
one of the most crucial things and i
think that you know
when you when you get to the level of of
highest levels of sophistication of
sensor technology diffusion of that data
the machine learning and ai algorithms
to
to do the digital signal processing and
to send the nudges that we were talking
about over to people
i mean yeah we can definitely more
rapidly catalyze that awakening so yeah
yeah it's gorgeous i i'm a huge fan and
i'm glad we got to
glad we got to show that too um
so i also want to
i want to say that for those that want
to also
follow anthony he had the links in the
bio below to his
uh instagram account um poetry by
anthony but yeah if you go
look at his account um you'll see that
he has poetry by anthony
again on instagram um he has a
ridiculous amount of really really
insightful
um quotes that he writes
on typewriter yes yeah which is which is
very cool
that it's og like that i love it
and they're really nice they're really
insightful highly recommend yeah
checking those out guys
um and then let's see here we kind of
got
we kind of got through a lot of our
points
i mean one of the other really nice
things is that it it's a
psychotherapeutic
so neurofeedback is psychotherapy so as
you elevate your state of consciousness
you're no longer immersing yourself in
those traumas
where you click the rewind button
incessantly and you go and you
replay all of the horrid um
and you when you butterfly effect
outward you butterfly effect out that
positivity and that that light bliss
consciousness to your family and the
community in the world
so i'd love to do i'd love to some type
like come back and do maybe one where
we i don't know we both ex i don't know
somehow we could do this
but like we both experience
neurofeedback or like demonstrate it or
show what's going on and like you can
you can wire up and
do some different ways and then we can
kind of see what's going on we talk
about your experience i think
be really interesting because i think
for a lot of people it's still a little
bit more
abstract but i think actually seeing
your experience seeing my experience it
could be someone else
it would be a fantastic way if we do
round two
with anthony will be uh will be demo uh
and unpacking the nuances of our
experiences
on the demo that'll be a really good
really really good idea
yeah yeah and it'll hopefully make it
more
um relatable and hopefully
we again it's the the democratization is
so
damn important um you know the
there's so many other sort of correlates
of awakening too
the neurofeedback's important hrvs a
really interesting one
you know having higher hrv is less
stressful
more hrv is more stressful or less hrv
is more stressful so you really
you really you really want to you know
you're more relaxed states of
consciousness you have higher heart rate
variability
if you're gonna you're gonna be stressed
you're gonna be like
just very on the same you know you're in
that
mode where you have to be yes mode and
that then that can maybe
neurofeedback show that it's more of a
beta
maybe state and then
i don't know what yet with the
microbiome that's one of my sort of
favorite ones to try and figure out but
i don't know what the the states of
enlightenment are
for the you know we have a we have
we have 2 000 yeah we have we have a
thousand
species of bacteria that each have 2 000
genes so that's crazy so that's you know
that's 2 million genetic expression
and that's you know 100x the human
genetic expression so
you know so i know a good person
actually that i think would have a
really
i'm not an expert on the microbiome but
she's super knowledge she's a
phd cancer researcher but super deep
into microbiome and mitochondria and
that's cool
all of these things and i think um
what's what's her name
her name's shauna shauna yeah i'll
introduce you she'll she'll be shout out
shout out shawna and uh we'd love to
have you on the program
let's do it that'd be great yeah i think
she'd be a good really good guest
i love i love people that are super deep
in those
like weeds of specific science specific
things yeah like i've learned so much
just in a few conversations with her
yeah and i'm into biohacking but like um
people there's there's people it's it's
really eye-opening to see people are
just like
can how to stack things like nad and all
you know what's that mean again nad is
um i forget what even stands for but it
basically
is like a it's like a reboot for your
mitochondria oh that's cool
yeah that's really cool it's a really
powerful yeah and she worked in a clinic
and and she kind of
understands like i don't even know for
example that you have like different
mitochondria types
oh yeah that's right and that like how
many other do you remember i never
forget but yeah oh yeah there's more
yeah i mean bio energetics
yeah yeah there's there's all this whole
thing so i'm still learning in that and
and for me just to bring it around like
full circle
um the more energized the body is i
think
the more um the better you're able to
meet the more progress you can make on
meditation it's hard to make
you know a sick body it's not as good a
meditation right but if you're really
healthy and vital and you're you can be
really energized on a cellular level
you have more prana that more prana that
can then
be moved and activated in ways that kind
of accelerates awakening so
the physical practices do help as well
and i think
um you know there's always been yoga and
diet and all of that stuff and those are
powerful fundamental sunshine clean air
water but
i think we are entering we're emerging
into this space where
there's all these nutrients and bio
hacking and technologies
um you know some like neurofeedback that
are exogenous and kind of just help
amplify what's going on in the brain or
in the nervous system but then there's
some you know
there's endogenous things substances
that you can take
because you interviewed like dr ted for
example right and he's working on a lot
of
dr tedda koso for those that want to go
watch that episode it's a super
fantastic one yes yes exactly so there's
a lot of things that will
um substances and nutrients and
different things that can potentially
help the awakening process and the body
help the meditation process in the body
so
it's um we're really trying it's an
exciting time that we're on this like
trailblazing cutting edge of really
a whole new science i think as science
and spirituality are kind of
merging more they are amen yeah exactly
yep and
hopefully uh the example that we were
talking about
about kind of before we started was that
we were trying to analogize them the
microbiome in a sense to also like the
connectome
of of of the brain or of your um
your brain waves that you're analyzing
because
you're it's potentially that even if
somebody doesn't go and experience
uh gamma and that maybe they
maybe their temperament and maybe that
that maybe it is
to be in maybe a more beta state it
like so maybe the quote like
living in the dao can be not only
like gamma but it can be
beta to yeah yeah that's kind of
interesting too there's a lot of
relativity too relativity which is
that's that's kind of a strange thing
too to to sort of say like
can you be in beta and be in unity
consciousness or something like that you
know is that possible
probably a problem yeah yeah and so this
is these are the
interesting questions this is like when
where perpetual kindergarten
as i love to say yeah i mean
wow uh okay i have let's see
there's really not that much left i mean
because we basically talked about
consciousness this entire
so you i love to ask people question
about what they think the nature
of consciousness is so
what do you think it is
um consciousness is
this is not my i mean i agree with this
um consciousness is
reality itself consciousness
is all existing all pervading
all present um love bliss
um that
is all of reality but also pervades all
of reality i guess
i don't know that's that's how i that's
how i perceive it
um yeah but
pure consciousness is is love
is love bliss is it's
that's god yeah and
everything that exists through every
it is everything it exists through
everything and
that's what we're waking up to
it's very interesting our our answers
on the show to the question range from
someone saying that it's subjective
storytelling or someone saying that it's
connections or someone's saying that
it's
infinite consciousness love bliss
um your
that is the baseline is that love bliss
and that
it's roomy quote
you know you you go around from room to
room looking for the diamond necklace
that is around your neck
[Music]
yeah i love
asking the question to
capture the perspective
of the nerve ending about
the reality that it's in you know it's
nice
and it's good getting the i definitely
agree
with you know that all of these
different answers it's so interesting
because my nerve ending agrees with the
nerve endings perspectives about
consciousness it's
because and you you see where subjective
storytelling
is is is interesting and true in its way
and that
connections are interesting and true in
their way and
the infinite love light bliss is true in
its way
that one seems definitely most
really most fundamental
most fundamental that's why satchit
ananda you know existence consciousness
bliss
is you know think about the words
existence consciousness
okay bliss
that's yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and and and another thing on that just
because i know that
that this is this this will help the
process for
for processing that information for
people is
one of the most interesting aspects to
existence consciousness bliss
is the fact of when you look at
this is in high level perception chapter
6 the biometrics of awakening section
that when you're in here and you're
looking at the classic
uh classical wealth hierarchy which is
usually the only way that we
portray the hierarchy of 8 billion
people on the planet
that you have the classic international
poverty at the bottom
and then you have the global middle
class the 225 000 ultra high net worth
and then the 2
200 billionaires and then there's a
little question mark around the
enlightened sages because you don't know
sometimes they may have no money
sometimes they do have money
and then on the enlightenment hierarchy
on the right you see
the enlightened sages at the top and
then in the
bubble where you don't know is you don't
know where the billionaires of the ultra
high net worth or the middle class
or the uh the international poverty are
and what's super interesting about that
right side is that you
may actually have some of
the planet's most wealthiest people that
are in the most
egoic states of consciousness and that
you might have some of the poorest
people on the planet in some of the most
enlightened states of consciousness
and then you wonder well what about
maslow's hierarchy of needs what about
the basic needs you know what if
how is it possible that someone that's
so primal because they don't have access
to clean water
how can they be existence consciousness
bliss
yeah i don't know but it's but it's
such a common archetype
rich people being miserable poor people
being happy but also poor people being
miserable because they don't have basic
needs met and rich people being happy
because they don't have to worry about
their basic needs
yeah it's all comes back to
consciousness what an enigma
what an enigma bro that one is
and it does it all comes back to that
consciousness undergoing this
exploration and i would say that
this exploration is one of many that
it's
that it's undergoing and did you um do
do you seem to think that this
reality is this one this universe this
one song
is one of many songs that infinite
consciousness is exploring
is that how you perceive yeah i agree
with what you've yeah you've said about
that i think so
um i mean it's a whole huge
rabbit hole but i think um yeah there's
no way that this is the only
in the vast universe that this is the
only yeah i mean
and this is all i mean if if this is a
projection or a simulation to
your entire show then and that's even
what like
mystics like ramana you know you would
say like the world that we see is not
real it's a projection
of mind well then if this is a
projection if this is just one project i
mean
there's probably infinite projections of
mind right that are happening
simultaneously so but we don't really
know that until we awaken
back to the all the way to the
it'll be good to get to that point where
we can actually see see the projector
yeah and not just the projection yep
yeah and and that that
in itself is what is most primal about
our awareness and our consciousness and
that
that sort of most primal it's
yeah it's like going back and back and
back
and not the coloration of the
of the experience that i'm having but
going back and back and back to the most
uncolored most primal
like the rupert spyro analogy of the
screen the screen before
there's the coloration of the experience
that's on the screen in the movie
so that's before that movie
that is being played on the screen it is
the screen it is the consciousness it is
that awareness that most primal
and that it's hubristic to think that
these the only consciousness is these
eight billion nerve endings on this
planet
and the dogs they're just less
of that consciousness and you know
like you just think about the the
hundreds of millions billions yeah it's
billions the billions of
animals that are slaughtered that are
raised and slaughtered the raising of a
little consciousness and
slaughtering it i mean it's a whole
that's a whole nother
thing like anyway that's a whole nother
thing uh life yeah
life feeding on life and like what's
above us feeding on us there's a whole
another um
let's uh let's let's hope that we can
maximize the basic needs of people
around the planet
regardless of whether they're
enlightened without basic needs or not
because nobody wants diarrhea and nobody
wants polio
nobody wants this [ __ ] so let's
eradicate it so that people don't have
to suffer
through that and then they can do
whatever they want with their time and
creativity and stuff like that so yeah
okay some silly questions
all right i've really been enjoying this
silly
segment okay on wrapping the shows it's
super fun
okay um okay
so the
first question is do you shower in the
morning or at night
morning in the morning yeah okay
and do you do that to kind of wake up
and get yourself ready for the day
is that why you prefer yeah and to start
with a kind of a clear
more clear energy or more of like a
reset
energy i guess yes
and then tell me do you shower for
approximately 10 minutes 20 minutes 30
minutes
five minutes where are you at in your
shower timing not too long i would say
like seven eight minutes
seven eight okay you're quick you're
that's a fairly quick shower yeah
length yeah yeah you're pretty much in
there maybe you have a couple shower
thoughts
a couple but you're in there mostly
efficiency
to move into the next yeah okay
um do you
[Music]
do you do uh
do you do shampoo conditioner and body
wash do you do all three do you only do
shampoo only shampoo and soap shampoo
and soap a bar of soap
no like a separate soap like a liquid oh
like a liquid soap that's not body wash
but it's liquid soap yeah okay okay i
see
interesting okay okay do you have a
loofah
no i don't sometimes i'll dry skin brush
before i shower
what's that mean try it like you take
the brush like those
long brushes and you brush your skin to
exfoliate
and allows it's good for your lymph and
so then and then you wash the dead skin
cells off when you go into the shower so
there's some people that say that that's
really healthy interesting so what is
this just like uh
like a like a longer thicker brush yes
you can brush your skin yeah oh you can
be in your back
yeah everywhere you're supposed to do it
whole body and like certain strokes that
kind of like move towards your
internal yeah wow oh whoa interesting
what's the name of the brushes usually
like um
you just get a minute i don't know in
either health food store like i think if
you just search dry skin
dry skin brush dry skin brush on amazon
you'll probably find if anybody wants to
follow the
anthony flora shower routine
[Laughter]
dry skin brush i love it um okay
and then what do you do you usually have
some shower thoughts
um yeah i usually
i usually will just more think about
what i have to do like
focus like actions for the day so
they're pretty
boring yeah actions though yeah
exactly like kind of like what's coming
up for the day
because usually i'll meditate first and
one of the reasons why i don't take
longer showers
is because um if you're meditating like
90 minutes in the morning
like before work is starting before all
you know all this other stuff starting
like you just don't have
kind of have to shave time off where you
can so yeah
um so yeah that's where i i would
cut time but i i in terms of thoughts
and i will
usually shower after meditating and
after journaling yep
so i've kind of gotten everything out so
it's more of like just my more pretty
concrete of like
okay what am i going to do this morning
yep
now do you um when you get to
your let's uh let's go on on to sleep so
when you're when you're going to bed at
night
you have to take your socks off how do
you take your socks off
um i kind of peel them down from the top
but i don't make them go inside out
which hand do you go with first
hand right hand right hand to left foot
yeah okay right hand to left foot and
then you peel them
yeah but you don't reverse them no i
don't reverse them yeah okay because i
don't want to have to like reverse it
yeah yeah and then you do the same thing
with the other one yeah on your left
hand okay
and then so then okay so then you go do
you sleep naked
no just in boxers or whatever yeah
shorts and a
yeah t-shirt shorts or shorts and a
t-shirt yeah and i have a chili pad
which is what's up which is like a thing
that cools your bed
so it has this like thin layer of
basically it puts a thin layer of water
on your bed and then it air conditions
kind of the water so it keeps your bed
surface very cool yeah so that then um
you don't toss and turn as much and it's
you go into deeper sleep basically oh
interesting so it's a cool biohack
huh wow so many of these bio hats
wow cooling pad on the bed yeah called
the chili pad yeah chili pad
yeah um do you
you sleep about what eight hours seven
eight hours something like that
varies i think weekends i sleep a little
more because i don't have as much work
but my workload's been really high so
during the week a lot of times it's more
like six yep and then maybe like eight
to nine on the weekends
yeah okay so i see i see and then
do you lucid dream not really i've never
been a big dreamer it's weird because
i know a lot of people are meditating
and doing all their very vivid dreamings
i
not not too much it's very rare that i
actually remember dreams do you write
them down if you do remember them
i do but yeah again it's like it's just
so rare
okay and then what do you normally when
you wake up
you're journaling and then meditating or
meditating meditating and then
journaling
and when you're meditating are you
usually doing neurofeedback on that
meditation yeah
sometimes i do it if i'm if i've been
pushing my system too much
i might um not do neurofeedback because
it is more intensity
but generally it's more deep
and more rewarding or more it's it's
it's more intense and i think
more there's more progress made if i'm
doing it with neurofeedback
so um i will i will tend to do
neurofeedback
um primarily probably like 75
of the time it's about the right ratio
yeah and then
do you have a procedure for do you
prefer to
sit in a specific way do you prefer eyes
open
i said um yeah it's very specific
i sit um i can't do full lotus
unfortunately but i do half
lotus i sit erect i sit on a cushion on
a pad so i don't have my back to any
to anything so um
yeah my practice is generally like 90
minutes um
and i'm able to stay i mean my legs do
get a little stiff at the end
but our hips or whatever but i can i can
stay there and then um
yeah i'll take the pic the ramana
maharishi picture like i was describing
and i'll start with eyes open that
usually produces a lot of delta
um and then from there i'll attend my
eyes will just tend to close organically
as and then that will shift more into
gamma and then they'll be more of a
love or a kind of ecstatic experience
but
it's not always like that and it's not
always like rainbows sometimes it's
actually like
a lot of monkey mind well um
there can be um the neurofeedback
doesn't produce that much
one of the benefits of neurofeedback is
the sound i think you focus on the sound
so that doesn't
it reduces the monkey mind because
you're not giving the the monkey mind
attention
and so it kind of fades into the
background and the sound becomes
prominent
um but where i'll say it's not like when
i say it's not all
like rainbows and love and light it's um
because sometimes there's like very deep
emotional
processing or healing or past life stuff
or things that come up i mean
there's a lot of purification that
happens i think
especially in gamma and really intent
when there's a lot of intensity
there like anything that's unresolved in
the system
i mean if it's moving you towards as you
move towards enlightenment or awakening
any of that karma anything that's
unresolved has to arise and it has to be
burned in kind of that fire of
spiritual awareness and so um
a lot of it it can be painful sometimes
um
but you're never given more pain than
you like you have the capacity to handle
i believe that as well so as my capacity
has grown
i get shown more stuff but then i i
process and
transcend that and then the experience
just gets richer and deeper
and more powerful so you come to respect
it and actually appreciate
exactly hardships yeah sufferings yeah
all of that
because those traumas trigger treasures
and the more that resilient you become
and the faster your bounce back speed
the more efficiently you integrate
and move on yeah yeah that's okay i see
and then what are you typically
journaling
i'm actually just exclusively journaling
on my meditation
experience um okay i probably should
journal separately for something else
but basically i'm just noting i'm
writing i'm documenting like what's
going on for me in meditation which
it's that's awesome which anchors kind
of yeah the experience and totally and
because it
whatever you experience in meditation
tends to be kind of very transient it's
hard to remember
yep um but also because i'm on this path
of like
trying to chart new territory yep in
in terms of using neurofeedback to kind
of speed up spiritual awakening
i also feel like it's good for me to
document what's going on with me so that
then
i can you know potentially share that in
the future right like share the whole
journey
and not just the end point of the
journey so that people can see like
at this stage this was going on and
that's right i was struggling with this
and i had this you know
these pains and these things going on
and this happened
so that later when there's all this
progress it's like people are like oh
yeah your doctor you're documenting your
your plate juggling
on the way to the stage where you're
gonna have the audience watching you
juggling but
they don't see all the broken plates
yeah and so it's nice to see
yeah and the profound realizations that
you've had along the way
exactly this is kind of like the
anthropology and archaeology of
the human race and um it really needs to
be taken a little bit more
seriously i'm glad you're doing the the
logging i think that journaling is super
important i mean i have
over 4 000 evernote files where over
700 conversations in just uh
you know in 2018 and 2019 i know
and so i think that the same style of of
process of documenting
your life in some way whether it be the
journal for meditation or
sleep journal or life journal or notes
or videos or
audio or books or whatever you do
leave some sort of trace of your
experience
and it's a very important cool
reflective process
also at the same time of healing and
there's different there's a lot of grief
journals there's a lot of really
interesting ways to
[Music]
yeah to do that documentation process
what
is your favorite food
uh it's i would say like
not healthy but like um there's
buffalo cauliflower at air wands oh it's
really good
that is so good yeah i got really
addicted to that before and then i had
to like
reduce it because it's fried and it's
not good yeah it's not healthy but
it's it's i don't know it's a good junk
food
yeah buffalo cauliflower that's favorite
for you yeah yeah
it wasn't always i think i was like
lasagna lasagna too oh my gosh
yeah jeez i just don't handle dairy that
well anymore um
no
it's kind of like a lasagna but with
eggplant and potatoes oh that sounds
great
and like yeah similar it's i think it's
in um
i forget which which cuisine it's in
anyways those are some of my favorites
wow yeah those yeah those do sound good
um and then let's see
let's uh let's let one last one
what is your favorite way to play
oh wow
um i don't know lately
this is going to sound very weird um but
i think you like weird to hear
i do i love weird i love it um
i've been experimenting with taking
cbd like lo no
little or no thc basically cbd through
vape or
another form um and combining it with
a brain um
mood booster brain kind of like spray
that this client that i work with
they have um it's this kind of juice
and nootropic yeah nootropic kind of
juice that you spray
and there's something about the synergy
of those kind of like creates a
um i don't know for me which i think is
unique to me but i think everybody has
that kind of their own really positive
experience it's kind of like a little
bit of like a mini ayahuasca
yeah kind of mistake like like we i feel
super altered and like basically um
but not like all it's weird not altered
in a in a way like i i'm completely
normal
yeah completely doing you're like
executing your
things that you need to get yeah exactly
but it's like it's almost like it's like
doing it in more
it's a different dimension it's almost
like it flips open a different dimension
slightly and
like it's there's a lot of joy and
lightness
and so it creates a very fun um because
you asked me like
favorite way to play it creates a very
playful environment or
but so yeah i'm happy to share that or
give you
whatever the links for the show notes
yeah that you can put in for that stuff
totally wow interesting so
i'm always fascinated by biohacking um
the in the nootropic space and so that's
really interesting yeah i've got some
great stuff to share with you there okay
cool we'll we'll give you guys another
report next time on how that's going and
we might uh show you guys on the round
two as well
maybe that would be a lot of fun yeah
yeah i could bring some that'd be funny
yeah
wow anthony what a blast this has been
yeah thank you
we crushed it so i'm so grateful yeah
thank you it's been a lot of fun
likewise yeah all things meditation and
neurofeedback
unity consciousness that's right
that's right thanks everybody
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below
so let us know what you're thinking and
also talk to more people about
meditation
about neurofeedback go and
making more routine practices in the
space
visualizing your data getting that
quantified self data stream
so you can see at a better level feel at
a better level
on a moment-to-moment basis daily
and check out again the link in the bio
below to anthony's
instagram profile go give him a follow
also check out the
links in the bio below to simulation you
can support us help us grow help us
flourish here in la
we have a lot of things we want to do um
i'll go ahead and say that one of the
things that i want to do as soon as
possible
and we would love your assistance with
this is being able to
have the show notes for every single
show
and so that it's broken up into those
segments really nicely
in youtube in order for that to happen i
need
that slight bit more assistance so help
join us in the community
so that we can get uh the transcription
team to
paid well so that they can do that for
us so that they can be chunked into the
sections
and support the other artists the
entrepreneurs the scientists the
spiritual leaders in communities around
the world that you believe in
help them flourish maximize human
potential
actualize your gifts build the future
we love you very much thanks for tuning
in
we'll see you soon peace